[Applause]
i want to go on the space shuttle that's
what i really want to do i want to go to
the international space station let me
be the first actor in space whatever
whatever title i don't care what it
takes you know get get me that ride i'd
love to do that tom told us about his
plans to fly into space back in 2002 but
long before he had a need for speed tom
had a need to succeed
i want to do everything i want to be
able to do anything i wanted to i mean
there's no really
just one role i mean i've got about
100 of them
how important is success everyone wants
to be successful i wanted to be
the best i wanted to be great as great
as i could be
tom turns 60 in july but when we first
met him in 1982 he was 19 years old and
ready to let loose at a new york
nightclub i love to
i thought what the dance i need a
vacation
yeah even back then tom's idea of a
vacation was just one night out
determined to make it big in hollywood
his work ethic would become legendary
his breakout role in taps was just the
first step in laying the groundwork for
his 40-plus year career
i like to be close to my films when
they're being made
seeing the transitions that the film is
going through i mean it's important for
me
you know to watch that to see that to
learn i was doing tasks i went to every
department and just studied what each
department did
yeah just to see how a film is put
together and how stories are put
together i remember laying in bed
thinking you know what
if this doesn't
if i never get to make another one at
least i got to make one
[Music]
i finished risky
about a year ago and just finished all
the rainbows i was ready um just you
know to carry a film
after the outsiders and tabs and
everything but still like anything a lot
of pressure you know scared to death
[Music]
you know that scene of dancing
which which i had done before i made the
movie you know dancing around the room
singing uh singing songs while no no one
was in the house of course hey
we didn't quit you quit i came here and
i felt you know really guilty about
everything that i had driving through
this town i
went back to my hotel room and i sat
there and i just like cried
and i realized that everything i have is
is a privilege and that you know i feel
that one of the reasons hopefully
you know god gave me what i have is that
he realizes i'm not going to take
advantage of the gifts
by 1985 tom was making all the right
moves to become the top gun that he is
today a three-time oscar nominee worth a
reported 600 million dollars and we were
with him every step of the way right now
i'm getting involved over the past
couple of years
more involvement in the overall process
of film in terms of developing
the script it's all been very calculated
i mean i really take my time in choosing
the films that i do and the people who i
get involved with and the great thing
about success is that
that i have the freedom in the room to
do that and i'm really taking advantage
of that i mean i researched this role
for two months
before i decided to do it
you know and i feel very thankful for
that luxury and that success
i've been having nightmares that no one
would show up except for my parents and
my girlfriend
but uh so i want to thank you all very
much how do you keep from becoming cocky
life is a humbling experience i don't
know how else to say it
if you want me to stop or you want to
give me any signal uh
grab my arm
[Applause]
the hand prints are now in i wasn't sure
if anyone was going to show up
[Applause]
it's a sexy
thing being a vampire tom also proved
two leading men can be better than one
when he shared the screen with brad pitt
in interview with the vampire i watched
this guy and he was fired
he was just fire
you know he took his
his stuff and he took it to another
level he took another direction i think
that's fantastic in london i rented a
go-kart track and we invited everyone in
brad and everybody came we just drove
around the track and just went nuts with
these go-karts and it was great after
that tom took a bite out of producing
his first movie in 1996 turning the 60s
tv show into a billion dollar franchise
[Music]
i thought man what we could do you know
this great theme music
and i just thought man i could just
picture the the trailer you know and
this story this has been a dream of mine
as a kid you know when i used to go to
movies it's you know now i'm making them
and i'm producing them and it's it is a
real pie
and we were there when he got braces at
age 40. it's not that bad actually it's
just to push these teeth out so that i
can close my mouth
that's how you know i didn't realize
that you could actually close your mouth
all the way plus we learned things like
tom's a hopeless romantic i like
relationships i enjoy the
the complexity and the
uh
intimacy of that what's your idea of the
perfect romantic night
definitely
uh you know candles come into play you
know
nice music
a beautiful walk under this moonlit
night or sunset on the beach
down to a picnic
those kind of things i i really love
along the way mr cruz gave us some of
the most iconic lines in movie history
portia
there is no substitute i want the truth
you can't handle the truth
you
complete me
it's so
amazing to me that
when you do something and then to hear
people say it back to you you complete
me i feel the need the need for speed up
if a lot of guys have used that
when you first came into the business
you gave yourself 10 years to make it i
think i've done all right
i just
love making movies i love what i do i
can't believe where i've come from in
the past since the beginning i mean when
i started out i know absolutely
nothing about really acting or you know
i just wanted to be an actor in looking
back i'm i kind of go wow i've you know
done i've done well there's that point
where you go that dream i remember when
i was doing taps i dreamed
if i could just do this the rest of my
life i want to make movies my whole life
and that was happening and now to have
spent you know the greater portion of my
life doing this it's really rewarding
[Music]